Hello there.
Chris Travis of Koenig & Bauer.
We want to use this video...
...to introduce you to a new dimension in large format:...
...our Rapida 145 and Rapida 164,...
...our two press offerings in large format.
Here today, we are on our Rapida 145 in our packaging center.
This particular configuration is a seven color, double coater, double delivery.
And then, we end with our new operator's office...
...where they are able to control the complete press.
This particular press, we have a wide variety of substrate possibilities.
We can print paper all the way up to flute, giving you maximum flexibility.
So we encourage you to get in touch with one of your Koenig & Bauer teams...
...to come and visit us here and test the new 145.
Because at Koenig & Bauer, we are on it.